jack hayes francine bus tél
bonsoir fonctionnement soir laurent
baffie francine distel des pommes des
poires et des scoubidous ville où partir
voilà bien alors le jeudi 22 juillet
dernier au petit matin sacha distel
s'éteignait francine dans votre
propriété familiale durée yole canada
elles et ils laissés inachevés un livre
sur sa vie qu'il avait commencé un an et
demi plus tôt en compagnie de l'écrivain
bruno tessarech et derrière le dernier
chapitre est resté sous forme de
synopsis alors c'est un livre important
pour sacha distel
parce que pour lui ça a constitué un des
éléments de son changement d'image et
oui c'est ce qu'ils voulaient lycée en
tous les cas sans savoir qu'il
laisserait aussi vie c'est un peu comme
son dernier cd dont il était venu parler
ici d'ailleurs qui s'appelait envers et
contre vous seriez vous voulez
absolument montrer qu'il n'était pas
seulement le créateur de chansons
rigolotes mais aussi un grand musicien
et un grand crooner un grand musicien
qui a écrit de très belles chansons qui
venait souvent la phase d oui mais comme
c'était la face à qui avaient du succès
forcément elles n'ont pas été voir un
temps connu que les autres sur livre qui
lui tenait à coeur énormément à coeur et
c'est pour ça que vous êtes là ce soir
pour en parler à sa place lui est là
c'est moi qui suis en première ligne et
je fais et je vais fait par amour pour
sacha parce que ce livre est important
pour lui il fallait que je vienne le
présenter donc vous allez nous le lien
voilà comment sens allons-y
c'est difficile pour vous de venir
parler de ce livre à la télévision on
vous a jamais vu en fait voulons au
contraire ça me fait plaisir bien on est
heureux que vous soyez là en tous les
cas voilà alors toute façon vous vous
croyez à la vie après la mort donc vous
pensez que sacha pas ma vie après la vie
oui c'est plus gai oui pensez que sacha
distel va vous aider ce soit
complètement
ouais alors dans ce bouquin sacha
raconte sa vie ses parents son père
émigré russe propriétaire d'un magasin
de luminaires à clignancourt bon danseur
son père un séducteur né un peu comme un
peu comme sacha et puis sa mère famille
juive bourgeoise
ils sont donc le fameux raymond ventura
ray ventura le créateur de l' orchestre
des collégiens qui sera à l'origine de
la passion de sacha pour la musique
c'est lui qui lui a vraiment donné le
virus étant tout petit laid il était
passionné est là on est à des des
concerts et sasha une aile coup de
foudre alors sacha raconte la guerre sa
mère arrêtée par la gestapo
les retrouvailles et en 1947 ray ventura
lui demande d'être le réveil matin d'un
artiste qui s'appelle henri salvador
pour ceux que paie lui sur le tournage
d'un film et henri salvador lui fait
découvrir frank sinatra et dizzy
gillespie toujours pour le compte de son
oncle sacha part aux usa en 1952 et à
l'âge de 19 ans il découvre stan getz
miles davis charlie parker
enfin c'est une révélation complète pour
lui complète et
oui c il a en fait commencé comme
musicien de jazz
voilà ensuite il devient directeur
artistique disque versailles chez son
oncle ray ventura et il devient le
meilleur guitariste français pendant
sept ans de suite
oui c'est vrai ces trucs que les gens
savent pas tout ça se passait avant moi
oui je suis quand même au courant
alors là on entre dans l'éducation
sentimentale de sacha distel ça se
passait avant vous aussi vous êtes un
peu plus au courant pas tellement j'ai
découvert beaucoup de choses au loin ils
inscrivent à ce qui veut dire quand même
c'est que sacha était incroyablement
beau métier magnifique vous vraiment il
était charmant et le charme c'est encore
oui c'est encore autre chose alors la
première c'est et juliette gréco c'est a
duré plus de deux ans et là on découvre
tout de suite quelque chose qui sera
récurrent dans les grandes histoires
d'amour de de sacha distel c'est qu'il
était un peu dominé par l
je pense enfin en lisant livre j'ai
découvert qu'elle était un peu une
initiatrice ouais mais le dominer parce
qu elle n'encourageait pas à chanter par
exemple les équipements par qui chantait
faux peut-être qu'elle voulait pas
perdre l'accompagnateur nom qu'on lui
donne alors jusqu'au jour où elle part
avec le producteur hollywoodien
d'arriver à nuque
c'est terrible la scène dans le bouquin
c'est à dire qu elle lui demande de lui
apporter son son passeport à la gare
et quand ils arrivent dans le
compartiment du vallon lit il trouve
gréco et ce dernier annexée pour
entretenir
détail amusant il découvre un monsieur
moustachu et juliette un peu trop près
de la moustache et il est très
malheureux très très très mal est-ce que
sacha est un sentimental grand
sentimental on le voit pas ce que ça
recommence encore avec jeanne moreau et
en parlant de jeanne moreau il dit c'est
une tornade amoureuse je sais pas ce que
ça signifie matt a bien une idée comme
way tornade amoureusement toujours
pareil l'huile est un peu complexés par
l c'est un peu le le petit jeune qui qui
accompagne la vedette fortrel bagages
voilà un petit peu voilà jusqu'au jour
où elle se casse avec louis malle à d'où
le nom du jeu
voilà ça c'est la deuxième donc ces
jeunes moreau et la troisième c'est
brigitte bardot alors brigitte elle
voulait faire des enfants avec le
voulait faire sa vie avec lui ah oui oui
était très très sincère oui elle était
très accroché par rennes accroché il lui
aussi
et puis chacun dans leur métier s'est
dit un petit peu c'est un ouais bah oui
il a toujours cette image avec elle du
dugas arriviste un peu gigolo pour mama
a n'ont pas dénoncé l'écart étant dit si
tu as un papier du canard enchaîné qui
est grave mais ça c'est la parole de
vérité le canard enchaîné ans est bien
dans le cas là on dit le petit jeune
homme qui essaie de se faire un nom à la
sueur de ce qu'on ne saurait trop nommer
ses plaisirs
jusqu'au jour elle le quitte
originalement il s'est fait plonger
charrier plusieurs fois il s'était
planté à chaque fois corey j'ai dit
ouais il l'a dit hier que nous on
imaginer sacha distel comme un mec super
séducteur et tout c'est vrai qu'il a des
filles formidables mais à chaque fois il
est dominé est planté oui il était
peut-être tombé huit penser à des choses
peuvent être plus sérieuses mais ces
derniers n'ont ouais c'est lui le
sentimental voilà alors il parle pas de
l'année straberg épouse vadim comment ça
se fait non c'est dommage parce que
c'est une des plus charmantes
elle est venue ici à votre place elle
nous a raconté son aventure avec sacha
en tous les cas ces trois aventures le
guérissent des stars parce qu'il dit
elle même qu'elle donc il prêt sans
intérêt
voilà il préfère quelqu'un peut être de
moins est magnifique voilà un et en 61
il tombe sur vous vous êtes au courant
là oui complètement complètement alors
sur vous vous n'avez rien à voir une
fille de banquier et championne de juger
entre vrai que ça change quoi
c'était plutôt la championne de ski que
la fille de manquer à l'époque c'est un
coup de foudre et ses sites par un c'est
vrai coup de foudre dit dès le premier
soir j'ai pensé qu'elle serait la mère
de mes enfants et qu'on aura un compte
commun il a rajouté
comment ça s'est passé la première fois
mais ça a été un coup de foudre
ouais j'étais tanné chef dans un
restaurant de téléphérique une coûteuse
et s'il faut préciser comment ça s'est
passé
j'étais en train de manger un petit
morceau après une descente et sasha est
rentré dans le dans ce restaurant et il
bavardait avec bruce de trois personnes
qui étaient là et tout d'un coup il
s'est tourné vers moi et il a eu cette
phrase d'une banalité incroyable je
crois que nous sommes déjà rencontrés ce
matin rue blanc oui c'est pas terrible
c'était en marche après ça marche 43 ans
quarante trois ans et deux enfants alors
votre secret c'est quoi si vous n'êtes
jamais mêlé de sa vie professionnelle
c'est pour ça que ça a duré aussi
longtemps au je pense pas que ce soit la
raison
non non non ça ça peut-être aidé non
mais vous aussi vous avez suivre en
femme indépendant vous avez organisé
votre votre vie de votre côté oui c'est
à dire que je vais j'ai une certaine
personnalité dirons-nous je suis une
sportive il ya des tas de choses que
j'avais envie de faire et j'ai continué
à faire je vais faire des trucs en
himalaya je suis allé me balader dans
certains pays avec mes copines
bon ça charal est un petit peu à cause
de mes absences mais finalement il en
était très fier que j'ai c'est cette
autonomie et 7
il sait rien passé dans l'himalaya quant
aux études parce que moi le cahier ti
non ma première femme m'a quitté après
un trekking dans l'himalaya très brun
tracking
ça fini c'est pareil mais c'est pas ça
le délai
et vous non non non j'aime bien les
népalais mais ils sont pas terribles
sérieusement bon ben vous le savez il
vous trompez temps en temps vous saviez
à l'époque non bien sûr que je savais
ouais et vous réagissiez comment disait
rien ou laisser passer l'orage
j'essaie passer l'orage c'est que j'ai
des parents qui ont divorcé quand
j'avais 17 ans j'étais ravi qui divorce
parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de se
bagarrer et c'était affreux et je
voulais vraiment réussir ma vie de
famille bon je suis tombé sur un homme
absolument charmant très agréable à
vivre
nous avions deux enfants et c'est pas
comme dans les films américains où il ya
une tromperie on casse tout on se tire
non gens souffrir quand même sur dix
souffrent r oui vous avez bien sûr bien
sûr mais je m'en suis remise
finalement au bout du compte ça a quand
même été une réussite
ouais c'est le danger quand épouse un
playboy aussi c'est un playboy c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit non playboy est pas le bon
terme beaux gosses j'en meurs beau gosse
charme est un tube talentueux non
c'était pas et que tu as n'ont pas dit
non on reste un beau gosse alors on
oublie que tu arrondir gens meurent par
contre les filles à wil énormément de
succès bien sûr quand vous mettez un
gourmand 1 devant devant une boulangerie
il ya plein de bons gâteaux il ya un
moment donné où ces diabétiques modèle
cassano est à sa droite
sans amour sans soucis sans problème
la belle on sent là on est pris et en
ça tourne au drame c'est la fameuse
affaire chantal nobel alors dans ce
livre c'est la première fois que sacha
distel s'exprime sur cette affaire et ce
qui est terrible c'est qu'il dit qu'il
éprouve toujours une grande
impossibilité en parler vingt ans après
oui mais ça a été très très très dur une
période de sa vie très très très dur
parce qu'il ya une une certaine presse
qui l'a entièrement démolie alors qu'il
n'y était pas pour grand-chose bons sont
les choses de la vie ça un vivant le
bouquin qui se rappellent plus de
l'enchaînement des faits non mais j'ai
des amis qui ont eu des accidents et
effectivement quand il ya une perte de
connaissance on oublie ce qui s'est
passé exactement avant et pendant
il avait perdu la mémoire de ce qui
s'était passé sur cette route
ce soir là oui absolument ce qui dit à
un moment dans les églises et je regarde
chantal nobel les deux chiens la porsche
le virage et je me retrouve elle est là
allongé mais c'est bien après oui je
pense de moi j'étais pas là mais je
pense que c'est comme ça que ça s'est
passé
alors pour vous qui prenez les choses
avec une certaine sagesse disons la
school has a dû être dur quand même dans
we sa part été très facile pas été très
facile g
mais c'est à ce moment là que toute la
famille se soude
oui et moi en premier vous l'avez
l'épauler ah oui complètement
on est passé à travers et les gars ont
été formidables aussi il puis mais ça a
duré longtemps quand même qu'on nous a
pas ménagé dans ce cas il raconte une
scène assez terrible si un jour il est à
megève
il voit passer chantal nobel qui a du
mal à marcher évidemment ils hésitent à
aller lui parler et c'est pas un manque
de courage d'ailleurs mais lily va pas
quoi parce qu'il sait pas trop quoi lui
dire qu'il n'ya pas grand chose à dire
moi donc choses à dire et c'est navrant
pour elle parce que comme il dit de
troncs d'arbres n'aurait pas été là et
elle n'aurait pas été aussi gravement
blessé ouais et là effectivement sa
carrière en prend un coup il perd le
contact avec le avec le public info ne
pense pas il perd le contact avec le
métier et parce que nous avons reçu
énormément de lettres justement de son
public qui ne comprenaient pas ce qui se
passait et je pense pas que le contact
avec le public a été coupée à ce moment
là je vois un mini lui ni moi n'avons
encore compris pourquoi ça a duré si
longtemps ça dure et qu'en même temps
moins disant ça le torturait les non pas
du tout
torture elle est trop fort comme vous
c'est l'ennui y est ils se posaient des
questions saltor tweedy qu'il y pensait
tous les jours mais il pensait mais ça
ne sortirait par l'unfp justement parce
que c'est un musicien qui continuait à
jouer sa musique et que excellent aidé
beaucoup alors ce qu'on va faire
maintenant francine on va écouter
d'abord les chansons de sacha les plus
connus il ya ensuite celle dont il
aurait aimé qu'elle soit les plus connus
didier
la vie par les eaux
ça ne peut pas durer comme ça
quel malheur la pression
instants après
ma semaine
oui
voilà sacha distel alors ça ce sont les
chansons les plus populaires
maintenant on va écouter les métiers que
sont interdits manqué toute la pluie
tombée sur moins 10 des transats vous
aux soucis sens propre
la belle on sent là
on est triste et ont très tôt
vous pensez qu'à toi
ok
et moi
je tendrais pour moi
tu es le soleil me tuerait le soleil les
jours toute la pluie tombe sur moi et
comme mort quelqu'un dans les souliers
sont au toit je veux bien croire car
toute la prétendue rhin
tous les toits
janot
l effort d ici qui aimeraient faire ici
rester
le dock son corps
voilà sacha distel sacha distel disparu
en juillet dernier à l'âge de 71 ans il
ne devait pas incroyable variété des
gens parce qu' il est mort jeune pour
tout le monde comme il est tellement
beau et bien conservé c'est incroyable
quand tu dis qu'ils l'avaient souhaité
les gens font ça jean piat est pareil
oui l'économie de la vieillesse g en
ad'autres la machin qu'on a revu la
semaine dernière il a pris 15 ans là
comme il s'appelait alors gérard darmon
ah oui